what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and I have watched the first two
episodes of Marvel's upcoming Disney
Plus show secret Invasion and I gotta
say it's actually quite a pleasant
change up of what we are used to getting
from Marvel recently now I've only seen
the first two episodes so I can't speak
for the entire series but I do have a
lot of positive things to say however
having said that I don't think this show
is going to necessarily be for everyone
and we'll dive into why I believe that
and why I also think it's going to be a
pretty great show with no spoilers this
is going to be a no spoiler review slash
reaction and of course when the series
do release online we'll go back to the
watch parties like we used to do it's
been a while since we've had a Disney
Plus show come out for Marvel Studios
but I am super excited to get back into
them now right away I just want to talk
about the quality of the show if Marvel
Studios is delaying everything which we
know that they have if you check out our
recent video we talk about every new
release date that Marvel just announced
announced yesterday they pushed a lot of
projects back including Avengers King
Dynasty and Secret Wars both back one
year with the apparent reason being to
focus on making better quality films and
TV shows and if that truly is the reason
and secret invasion is a good example of
them focusing on quality then I think
that the MCU is in really great hands
right now and the direction they're
going is really fantastic because I do
think that secret invasion is a step up
from what we've gotten recently with the
exception of Guardians of the Galaxy Vol
3. it very much feels like Captain
America Civil War you get the same vibe
from it and what I really like is that
it actually puts a lot of realism into
it you feel some things from real life
kind of bleeding into the show not in a
forced way but in a sort of real
relatable way in fact the opening of the
show talks about and again without
giving anything away but it kind of just
makes you think well everyone can kind
of be tracked right now right I mean
just because of our phones and the
internet think about Target targeted ads
that specifically Target things that you
are interested on based off of your
browser history what you've searched on
the internet Etc they paint that picture
for you but then take it even further
and I gotta say the threat of the
Scrolls to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
to that world that all of our heroes
live in that threat is a lot bigger than
we really perceived I think even to
people who might have read The Secret of
vision Comics I still think it hits a
little differently because of course it
is live action and in a world where we
have the Avengers in it the scroll may
not seem like such a huge threat to
everybody before going into the show but
going into the show the first and second
episode do show us that no they are
indeed quite a very very real threat and
are actually a threat to human existence
as we know it but it's not just saying
that it's making you feel that by how
The Show Goes about portraying the
threat so right away I think it starts
off feeling very very heavy it's got a
really great opening sequence that I
think a lot of people are really going
to enjoy and I gotta say there are some
twists and turns and some surprises in
the first couple of episodes again no
spoilers but there were some surprises
that I truly was not expecting and I'm
still kind of waiting for it to turn
back around again I can't wait to watch
the other episodes and figure out how it
all ends because right now I am
genuinely curious as to how the story is
going to play out with very specific
characters and overall you've got a lot
of different characters in this and what
I love about this show so far is I
actually am always questioning who is a
scroll for example there are plenty of
times during both episodes where I'm
like Nick Fury are you a scroll is this
a scroll disguised as Nick Fury right
now because sometimes you know okay this
is the real Nick Fury but then in a
couple of other scenes you're like wait
is this Nick Fury or is it a scroll the
same thing goes with Agent Hill
sometimes you're like okay this yeah
this is her but sometimes you're like oh
no wait it's a scroll and I really do
want to give credit to them for this
because there are genuine parts
throughout the entire episodes both of
them where you truly don't know even
when Roadie comes in you're like wait
has Roadie been a scroll this entire
time the fact that you really don't know
and are asking that question throughout
this series is really really cool to me
and that really draws me in now I've got
plenty of great things to say about this
but one thing I did want to talk about
like I mentioned was this might not be
for everybody because it's not the
typical Marvel Superhero film and it's a
little bit slower it is there are some
good action scenes I really did enjoy
them there are some flashbacks that are
really cool as well but overall the pace
of this is a little bit slower because
it's a little bit more heavy so there's
no Iron Man flying through the air
there's no Thor coming down from Asgard
through the bifrost or with this Hammer
Hulk's not coming into Smash and Nick
Fury does kind of explain I'm not
calling the Avengers this is my fight
plus there is kind of a threat of
calling in the Avengers and Nick Fury
explains this very very well I won't say
exactly why but basically there's a
threat to kind of letting more people in
on what exactly is going on and the
scroll threat is a lot bigger like I
said than everybody has thought even
Rhody even the president of the United
States even Nick Fury himself didn't
realize how big of a threat the scroll
actually are and we've been theorizing
about this for a while now imagine if
the president of the United States was a
scroll imagine if a high military leader
was a scroll imagine if the leader of
Russia the leader of China North Korea
imagine if all of these people were
scroll obviously that would be a huge
threat for the scroll who actually want
to take Earth for themselves that is a
huge threat to everyone else in the
world so the story is heavy and the
story is very intriguing and it's really
really good but if you're looking for
that more fast-paced action all of the
time Tony start flying through the air
is Iron Man shooting blasters that's not
what we're getting in this it is
definitely a spy Espionage Thriller and
I do really like it for what it is for
what they were going for I do think it's
pretty dang near perfect again I've only
seen the first two episodes so I can't
speak for the entire series but I did
really enjoy these first two episodes
and I do think we are seeing kind of a
different side of the MCU and a
different side specifically of Nick Fury
which I did truly enjoy he is a lot more
vulnerable in this show than we have
ever seen him before and even some of
the clips that have come out have shown
that other people are kind of worried
about him as well Maria Hill is stating
you don't really seem like you're up for
this you don't really seem like the old
Nick Fury that I'm used to knowing and
in a way he's kind of not and they do a
really great job at explaining why and
it's very realistic as much as it can be
for a world where superheroes exist and
half of the population got snapped Away
by Thanos and there are aliens secretly
disguised as humans on the planet but
it's actually a really cool thing
because it really makes you wonder in
the show they tell you oh yeah this
would be so far-fetched for aliens to be
taking human shape right but they are
and I think they do a really excellent
job of kind of making it relatable to
real life a little bit and one thing
they did extremely well is the ending of
the first episode in the second episode
you are sitting there like wait
what and you are genuinely concerned and
confused and a little bit scared for
what's going to happen but most
importantly you are hooked into wanting
to know what is going to happen next and
I think that's what a great TV show does
for me that's what I really loved about
Loki and one Division I had no idea what
was coming next they threw so many
twists and turns and they ended each
episode with us really wanting more
wanting to know what was going to happen
next that is something that we actually
didn't have with She-Hulk it was kind of
a different story each time that we saw
an episode of She-Hulk eventually did
kind of connect a little bit more but
that is something that I've missed with
these Disney Plus shows and this really
does bring that back you want more you
don't want the episode to end you want
the next episode right away and you're
just dying to know what is gonna happen
how is this going to end are people
going to die who is really a scroll
who's not a scroll have any of the
Avengers been scroll it's honestly
really fun to think about which is
really interesting because this is a
very serious show which I do enjoy about
it and the cast just shines they really
do the cast shines in this the cast is
phenomenal everybody does an insane job
I mean it's Emilia Clark it's Samuel L
Jackson it's Ben Mendelson Kobe smolder
I mean the cast is just incredible they
do what they do they act and they're
amazing at it they draw you in to this
world with their characters and for the
future episodes I am expecting a lot of
twists a lot of turns a lot of surprises
because we've already got them in the
first two episodes and I gotta say some
of them are pretty big obviously some
bigger than others and again no spoilers
but I couldn't really believe that some
things were actually happening and even
now you don't really know what is true
or not because one thing could happen to
a character and you're like well was
that actually the character did this
character actually just do that or was
it a scroll pretending to be that
character who did that and that's the
threat that's the big threat is that
literally anybody you know if you're
Nick Fury anyone you know could be a
scroll Maria Hill Everett Ross Talos
himself and the cool part is is that you
do see the scroll shapeshift into a lot
of different people so it makes it very
apparent hey you never know and we don't
ever know so that's really a cool thing
there we're kind of right alongside of
Nick Fury there where Nick Fury goes I
can't trust anybody and we're like yeah
you really can't trust anybody so
overall I think the first two episodes I
think they were great again they're a
little slower paced but they are very
intense and they really have you on the
edge of your seat and they really are
making you want more and making you
wonder what exactly is going to happen
so I really enjoyed that I thought they
were a great watch I think the story is
fantastic so far the action scenes that
we did get are fantastic I have zero
problem with anything visually that we
saw I think it was all great I really
don't have any complaints this is
exactly what I expected from it I think
it's going to be exactly what a lot of
fans expect from it but even better
because I think this story is a little
bit better than I expected it to be and
I gotta say I'm hooked I'm really
wondering what is going to be happening
and I think a lot of fans are going to
be as well so it's great so far again
can't speak for the rest of the series
but the first two episodes fantastic so
far can't wait to see the rest let me
know how excited you are for secret
invasion in the comments down below and
don't forget to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on the MCU and enter our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
and some DC items as well winner gets
pick one item and we pick a winner at
the end of each month as always thank
you all so much for watching wolf
foreign
me